مناشدات النار الآن النار الآن النار الآن النار الآن
بملاييننا في
ملياراتنا هذا مارس يبدأ الآن في
وسط لندن ولكن الوجهة النهائية
هي سفارة الولايات المتحدة في جنوب
لندن وهذا هو المفتاح هنا،
الغضب الذي نسمعه هو في الغالب
موجه نحو الحكومات الغربية
وخاصة الولايات المتحدة
لدعمها لإسرائيل في شهر واحد هناك
أكثر من 4000 طفل يموتون وهذا ليس
طبيعيا أريد فقط أن أقول إنني يهودي وأنا
أؤيد تماما هذا مارس وكل ما
يحدث اليوم لماذا
يمكن ذلك؟  "نحن جميعًا ندافع عن
الفلسطينيين، لذلك على الرغم من الجدل
والفترة التي سبقت هذا الحدث، فقد
ظل الحدث منظمًا للغاية وسلميًا إلى حد ما،
لكن حجمه يعكس ما نشهده بشكل
متزايد من هذا
المزاج العام المتنامي الذي على الرغم من الهجمات المروعة
في 7 أكتوبر  وربما
ذهب الرد إلى أبعد من ذلك